we have another question that came in
it's much more lighthearted and what's
the his name is nafisa Mustafa okay
I'm just hoping for like another dude
and Aziz commented before he's been
great he writes what would your advice
be to aspiring filmmakers so let's
suppose somebody's 14 again but not with
a mini DV this time they have 4k or you
know they have just an amazing sort of
camera that they're doing for the love
you know when I was growing up in
Rockford being a filmmaker it was just
such a realistic thing I was just doing
it for the love right
I was emulating things it felt good to
be creative but in terms of like making
in terms of making a film
you know these things take years so like
don't pick something that you're not
truly passionate about pick something
that you care about more than just
making a film about and I think everyone
because of their personal experience
because of where they come from because
of the way they think everyone has at
least one story with them themselves
that only they can tell and nobody else
can tell I think people should honor and
respect that for themselves and I don't
just mean making a personal film about
themselves that you know I mean it's
just that we you know we really need to
sort of have understanding across many
different aisles and lines that seem a
little bit more to highlighted these
days you know lines of division
absolutely what did you use to film the
movie with from the mini DV 2 there were
other shots that definitely weren't mini
DV there were I mean all that stuff I
don't really I considered all that stuff
archival but so filming it with three
different DSLRs and c300
you